you ever have a moment of friction with  Phil were you not needed to have a  conversation with them or no because you  know coming from a disciplinary my  father was a drill sergeant and I  understand you're militaries but  wasn't allowed to talk back  wasn't allowed to be afraid wasn't  allowed to make excuses  so whatever I put my mind to I had to  get it accomplished or else  and you know even though it was a  professional making a lot of money I  still had that mentality that if I don't  get this done I'm going to get in  trouble by my father and I never wanted  to get in trouble by my father so always  you know did did things a certain way  [Music]